President Trump just unified Republicans
in Congress to pass major tax reform and
now they face a possible daca deal a
huge boost if they get lucky and
infrastructure spending and the budget
to deal with but what impact will
discuss between Steve ban and and
President Trump have on the President's
agenda to discuss I'm joined by
columnist and Coulter in New York one of
the earliest and strongest Trump
supporters and also in New York is
national review editor rich Lowry who
was less than an enthusiastic supporter
at the outset of Donald Trump both of
you it's great to have you on different
perspectives on this perhaps but let's
start with you and on this Bannen Trump
feud some wild legal implications for
both Steve and perhaps the president's
team which I find kind of wild that he
might have said these things given them
appetite for mom Muller and the
Democrats what they want but but on the
issue of the agenda the Trump agenda do
you see any impact here no really not at
all I don't know whether to believe the
quotes I haven't heard anything from ban
and there's an the book review editor of
The Washington Post just posted an
article saying that there are some
credibility issues with Michael Wolf
though it may mean a lot of it's a fun
read there were a few good points Bannon
made the stuff about pro-russia was
completely insane so it kind of
surprises me that he'd say that treason
treasonous and unpatriotic that to take
of me I'd put that in a shame camp the
same camp there's a lawyer up to Trump's
office like I mean who knows whether I
don't mean I doubt that some but two-bit
lawyer from Russia was taken up to the
26th floor that just saying to me that
seems no apparently he wasn't but but he
also said if you want to have a meeting
like this what you do is you send your
lawyers to unmarry on New Hampshire well
Hillary did a lot more than that but
yeah you
wander it it was kind of a stupid
meeting Hillary paid 12 million dollars
to the Russians to get dirt on Donald
Trump so no the Russia stuff has been
boring and stupid to begin with I don't
think it's really going to have any
effect although I mean it's clear that
the media has no idea why Trump won I'm
starting to wonder if Trump and Bannon
have any idea why Trump won the issues
that Trump ran on and I wish you would
always have me on when you're talking
about dreamers or immigration or is
immigration immigration immigration
trade and no more Wars the trade deals
are easy then no more Wars ought to be
easy doesn't seem that easy but it's all
about immigration and and I mean in this
last to be fighting about the Alabama
election there were there was a great a
great member of Congress running in that
election Trump didn't endorse um yes
Annan was in the White House at the time
that's not and I want I want rich lot to
get on this because they're not debating
immigration I agree with them on the
immigration laws Trump has no no no but
I'm saying what I'm saying sorry they
were driving Alabama right comments and
the wolf in the wolf account again we're
going to learn more about this whether
it's true not I'm sure we'll hear from
bana at some point but the rich on the
issue of immigration
look there's it's tons of room to argue
with any dr. Deal or gosh should we
build the wall have 10 years of
enforcement before we ever entertain a
daca deal that's a legitimate debate
that you know people like Ann and myself
and Bannon would probably have with with
some of the Trump folks but that's not
what this was about
again this is one excerpt of a book we
don't know what else is in this book
there's could be and I'm sure there's a
lot more but your your take on this this
aspect of it but we have other people
who are quoted in the book who are
contesting the quotes so we don't know
100% whether he used this this neutral
nuclear war word of treason but it is
consistent with blind quotes we've seen
over the last year where Bannon is
really hates Jared Kushner and thinks he
was doing something untoward with Russia
and look I obviously had my reservations
about Donald Trump but I do want him to
succeed I think the fact was in the
White House been an alienated a lot of
people he
did spend a lot of time leaking he got
fired for leaking when he called out of
the blue a left-wing journalist from the
American Prospect and Alabama was a
debacle
and when these allegations came out and
a lot of them were credible Ben didn't
back off in the least he proudly
continued to support
Roy Moore and got Donald Trump involved
and dumped for Donald Trump winning is
very important and the fact you look at
the last month Bannon led him into a
debacle in Alabama where as Mitch
McConnell and Paul Ryan bannon's
nemesis's actually passed a huge part of
the Trump agenda that's the biggest
legislative accomplishment so far and do
you find it interesting or perhaps
ironic that the establishment is or
frightening that the establishment is
rallying to Donald Trump after this
excerpt is released oh yeah of course
it's terrifying and you see I
anticipated riches riches a response to
bring up Alabama know that mistake was
Donald Trump's that's why I say I wonder
if Donald Trump knows why he was elected
why would he endorse Luther strange it
was a disaster on immigration when mo
Brooks was running at least in bannon's
defense he was still in the White House
and couldn't endorse anyone during the
original primary it was and if you have
to choose between I mean neither Roy
Moore or or Luther strange or great on
immigration we could have counted on Roy
Moore just cuz he would have voted again
like McConnell right but now we're gonna
litigate Alabama but how does this war
of words help the conservative populist
agenda I would say it does no I don't it
at all Noah no it doesn't help it but I
also think it doesn't hurt I just think
it's utterly irrelevant
I mean Macomb County Michigan didn't
vote twice for Obama
and then Trump for so that the hedge
fund managers could keep the carried
interest loophole they didn't vote for
tax cuts well I didn't for Steve Bannon
and the fact is there are a lot of
people who are in favor of this
immigration agenda still around Donald
Trump Stephen Miller very effective guy
Tom Senator Tom cotton from Arkansas
very influential with this White House
so the idea that Steve mana has at least
betrayed in the
that he somehow uniquely understands
Trump and was uniquely responsible for
the election victory was another thing
that was rub Trump the wrong way and
another reason this is probably this
breakup has been brewing for a long time
all right guys thank you so much